welcome to the week in 60 minutes from
spectator tv
recorded on thursday november the 19th
on this week's show we'll look at the
continuing
fallout since dominic cummings was
booted out of 10 downing street last
week
boris johnson's efforts to reboot his
government with yet another green new
deal
and the latest from the brexit
negotiations which
really do seem to be entering the end
game
at last we'll be joined by katie balls
the spectator's deputy political editor
she's
written this week's uh cover story on
the prime minister
robert peston itv's political editor the
spectators political editor james
forsythe
and wolfgang mung chao recently of the
ft
now director of euro intelligence
and before we go we'll also take a quick
look at mr trump's election lawsuits
with our u.s editor freddie gray and
with candice own the
radical conservative commentator
formerly
the campaign group turning point and the
author of blackout
now if you're watching on youtube
subscribe to our channel just tap the
red subscribe button
below this video followed by the bell
icon
which appears afterwards this way you'll
never miss a deficit as always a special
thanks to charles stanley for supporting
this episode of the week
in 60 minutes charles stanley is one of
the uk's leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
we start with the johnson
administration's efforts to relaunch
itself
in the wake of the civil war inside
downing street
now we know who the casualties were but
what's the direction now for the
government
and does boris johnson have the stamina
or the wit
to head out to pastures new this week's
spectator cover story
is boris in a spin it's by katie balls
she joins me now as does robert peston
and
james forsyth so uh katie yet another
green new deal more for defense less
perhaps
for international aid is this the start
of a
major reboot for mr johnson well it
depends who you ask and i think what's
really striking about this
reset and we've been told by some senior
figures in government this is boris
johnson's
reset week um no one seems to be able to
agree on how big a change this is on if
there is a new policy direction if it's
still
very much what it was before and i think
it points to the fact there is a vacuum
in government right now
we know dominic cummings and lee kane
have gone we know that there are some
figures in the ascendancy including
allegra stratton
the prime minister's new spokesperson
who's now taking the lobby briefings
and but yet we we're still trying to
find out who the key players are going
to be
what's really struck me this week is if
you you know walk around westminster
everyone seems to have a spring in their
step tory mps will wax lyrical about
what a new dawn this
is a happier era for boris johnson
cabinet ministers are you know cockahoo
to be honest and that's enlarged because
they think they're getting their power
back
we're returning to a cabinet government
but yet when you
delve a little bit deeper all these
factions seem to think that
this uh is going to be a new era in
which the prime minister listens to them
a lot more
you had the one nation group this week
have a meeting on zoom where they talked
about how they could use this
opportunity to move the prime minister
to the center
and you also have a northern research
group talking about how it's going to
mean more money for the north
libertarian mps even think this is good
news for ending lockdown
i'm not convinced they're all going to
be satisfied once we get
uh boris johnson having to make
decisions i'm pretty convinced they're
not all going to be satisfied that's the
way politics is
what do you make of it robert you
sometimes wonder whether
all these policy announcements that come
out especially this stuff on the green
new deal not much of which is actually
that new um
is is not being pushed so much because
they believe in all these things and
turn downing street but that mr johnson
is desperately trying to find new ways
of defining himself and moving things on
look uh it's it's been a grim period for
all of us it's been a grim period for
him uh the country defined by the kovid
19
crisis and that is going to continue
um he's desperately trying to offer us
uh proof that he's got you know other
sort of tricks up his sleeve uh a plan
to regenerate um i was very struck by
what katie said about
you know a spring in uh ministers and
officials
step uh look i have to say i think this
is a sort of false dawn
um you will be acutely aware
andrew uh about the economic and
fiscal and indebtedness cost of all of
this
next week we will see the projections
from the office of budget
responsibility of quite how much debt
we've accumulated so far and how much
more debt
um the country is likely to
uh or the government is likely to have
to take on as
uh this economic malaise which is
associated with this virus
continues i think that's going to be a
very big and very
shocking moment for the tory party and
for the country and i think the
realization that this indebtedness will
be defining the politics of the next
five
years um will uh in a sense
make everything else that's been
happening over the last few days in
terms of the soap opera of downing
street feel pretty
insignificant and i i also think one
other points worth making about dominic
cummings um yes it's true that personal
relations
within downing street had become toxic
um and i think many people would say
that both dominic
cummings and lee kane didn't handle
their personal relations within
government optimally
but if you talk to senior people at the
center of government
including senior civil servants they say
one thing about dominic cummings which
is that he had
big ideas uh and he was an
energizer of groups of people within
government for change
and the prime minister will miss that
there is
nobody in downing street um creating
a big agenda for him now that cummings
has gone
people focus on the need for a chief of
staff and of course
downing street needs to be better
organized but downing prime ministers
also need people
with big ideas and boris johnson is
frankly for all his
uh you know for all the strengths that
his colleagues thinks he have he is
never some he's not somebody
who is associated with an ideology and
with ideas
um so he will need to find somebody to
replace cummings
and pretty fast i think james i was uh
re-reading because that's the kind of
person i am
gordon brown's new deal of 2009
uh he promised uh 400 000 new jobs he
promised all sorts of more wind turbines
and a new agreement green economy indeed
a recovery on the back of green
investment so here's your starter for 10
today james
what's the difference now between boris
johnson and gordon brown
i think one of the big differences is
that how the technology has developed i
think i mean i think 10 years ago
shifting to more green energy was going
to be very expensive for households
i think now you know off the price of
offshore wind has fallen quite
dramatically
and so i think that that is the
difference i i think there is an
interesting question which is
as one minister put it to me uh a few
months back you know there's no doubt
that on this stuff boris johnson is a
green keynesian you know he thinks that
you know you've got to get demand going
again
so you might as well spend it on green
stuff and i think
you know i think a lot of tories view
the net zero by 2050 target as
you know yes it's something that's
signed up to in law but it's not
something that keeps them up at night
i think that boris johnson does take it
a bit more seriously than that
i think there is an interesting question
here which
is as as robert said is the government
going to end up suffering from kind of
political long covid
as the public finances are left in such
a poor state at the end of this
crisis or are we going to see with the
vaccine and the like
but the economic rebound is perhaps
slightly sharper than expected
and and that would enable boris johnson
to play the role but he's much more
naturally suited to than yet than he has
been to dealing with this pandemic which
is you know being the booster-ish figure
trying to get the animal spirits and
confidence moving
robert you mentioned the the deficit
figures are going to get next year
they're going to be eye-watering amounts
of money we'll be borrowing
and huge additions to the national debt
huge increase to the
the deficit the budget deficit this year
and next and probably
as far as the eye can see the politics
of this are interesting though because
it looks like the british tories are a
bit like the american republicans
that they're not deficit hawks when
it's their guy in power and uh i think
you'll see now
you know trump was the opposite of a uh
i mean he was full of fiscal
incontinence
and the republicans pretty much helped
kept their power to drive they didn't
complain too much
now of course it's not their guy that's
going to be in the white house they'll
rediscover their fiscal
hawk credentials so it looks like the
the tories as long as they're in power
they will not be the fiscal hawks
they've been
look i'm sure that's right i mean let's
be clear um you know
boris johnson looks sort of almost
nauseous
when he is forced to address the
austerity question he does not want to
return
to austerity and as james says um
whether he would uh define himself quite
as explicitly
as a keynesian as james has said he
undoubtedly is a keynesian
um in reality he's in practice i mean
i'm not sure he would know what a
keynesian is
in terms of economic concept but in
practice that's what he's become
mind you maybe we're all keynesians now
i think as somebody once said robert
well look it's it's very uh you know
hard
uh if you just look at the politics of
this country to
um argue that it's you know a great idea
uh
politically uh to go back
to austerity but i think there's a very
big there's there's a much bigger point
here which
um you'll be aware of and it is this
across the west we are seeing the most
dramatic rise in indebtedness
uh in our lifetimes far greater than we
saw even uh after the banking crisis of
2007 to 2008
and what that represents since we are
seeing an economic recovery
in um we are seeing an economic recovery
in um asia is the most
uh with the fastest transfer of
economic power relatively speaking from
the west
to china and other asian countries
and economic power as we know uh
translates into
a political power too and i don't think
really that any of the west has
really woken up to the long-term
significance
of the relative mismanagement of covet
in the west compared
to asia and what that means in a very
profound
sense for the balance of power the only
good thing to say about the uk
is that pretty much the whole of the
west is in this together it is not
just a uk problem although you could
argue
that our finances are deteriorating a
bit worse than elsewhere but everywhere
we are seeing this problem
and i uh the one thing that does i think
alarm me though is even though it's a
collective problem for the west
the point that you just made about the
republicans and i think we can now
translate that into
the view of the democrats too as they
take power in the white house
is that america constantly takes comfort
from the fact that
it is still the world's most powerful
economy and
it has the reserve currency the rules
that apply to
us the worries that apply to for example
europe about indebtedness
simply don't apply to the us
yet because international investors have
to own u.s debt
they don't however have to own european
debt and i i i fear that
there are all sorts of very difficult
questions that governments across the
west are going to have to ask over the
next year and i
i don't even think they've begun to ask
themselves uh
these questions these are epoch changing
times indeed they are katy coming back
to the relaunch or attempted relaunch of
mr johnson's government
in terms of policy any idea what else we
can expect
i think what's interesting was last week
you had a few briefings going out by the
idea that
boris johnson his reset was gonna
involve a less dogmatic approach on
scotland
uh a push on women's issues and also the
environment now
we have the ten point plan but i do
think it's worth bearing in mind
that a lot of that was in the works
before you know dominic cummings and lee
kane left
there was a debate about the timing of
this announcement some don't think
it's a great idea to use in the middle
of a pandemic or a lockdown
and but in terms of the other areas i
think we're just in such a state of flux
and what's quite interesting is this
uh when you speak to senior figures in
government now about what they want to
do
i think number 10 were taken aback by
the idea that they were going to have
this big pivot so boris johnson has
spent a lot of this week and he is in
self-isolation this week it's worth
pointing out
after the test and trace app uh pinged
him and you know
speaking to tory mps and trying to
reassure them
that he's still committed to the level
up agenda um
but i think what you keep hearing is let
boris be boris
i've lost count of the number of times
i've heard cabinet ministers say that
tory mp
say that his senior advisors say that
but the question we then come back to
and why i think it's all quite murky is
well what is boris johnson's agenda
because we hear what carrie
simmons agenda is we've heard a lot
about what dominic cummings agenda is
and that's why for all the positivity
right now in westminster
from tory mps about where this is going
about being listened to more
the more senior figures of government
you speak to i think the more skepticism
there is
and i've had several senior members of
government say to me this week you know
the problem here is you can change all
the staff in the world
if you still have a prime minister you
can't make a decision and stick to it
it's not going to make a little bit of
difference and i
also heard him compared to a weathervane
you know somebody constantly changes his
mind
and that's why although we're getting a
sense in terms of the defense spending
um even things such as you mentioned in
your introduction
international aid could be cut for a
year we know that something the
chancellor wants as a way of trying to
you know pay for lots of things that
he's being asked to pay for
while trying to you know stop debt
spiraling further
now there's a very big effort right now
in government just
to make boris johnson not do this uh
there are tory mps ministers
lobbying for him to not reduce
international aid and there's
this sense that he will say one thing to
one group listen to another and change
his mind so even that isn't definite
and i think that means that when we're
talking about what this reset really is
it goes back to robert's point
which is we have had uh you know figures
leave government who had strong visions
and those who spent a lot of time at
boris johnson are not sure what his
vision is other than a few things we've
heard this week
no i have uh no idea when people say let
boris be boris i have no idea
what they're talking about when people
said let reagan be reagan
or let thatcher be thatcher i knew
exactly what they were talking about
uh i've no idea what it means in mr
johnson's
case but let's let's come to the
question uh
katie i want to speak to james in a
minute as well again then come back to
robert but let's come to the question
the the big question that everybody
wants to know the answer to
what's the truth about carrie simmons
role in 10 downing street
look i think she is clearly a very
influential figure i think that
we've clearly got to a point now where
that person is being written about on a
daily basis as a profile of carrie
simmons and this week spectator 2 but
also just in the newspapers i think
we've moved from a point where a couple
of weeks ago
you know she didn't get so much
attention in terms of her views what
she's doing behind the scenes
to the fact that in a way she's getting
as much air time in terms of views
as boris johnson what i've been really
struck by is one of the things that
mps and ministers expect and and i think
even those in downing street say is
going to happen is a cabinet reshuffle
timing not not so sure i think there's a
sense that you might want your chief and
staff in place first but it's not being
completely ruled out this side of
christmas
and i think when you start talking to
people saying oh who's going to be up
and down in the reshuffle
i'm struck by the number of tory
politicians who will just
really go in by saying well i think it
could be this person because
carrie simmons worked with them it could
be this person because carrie simmons uh
you know favors them
and i think that shows that um in terms
of a political broker
she is judged within the tory party as
someone with immense influence
well robert listening to kate it sounds
that
in a very different way but still in
terms of influence
at least for the moment while there's
something of a vacuuming turned down in
the street carrie simmons is the new
dominic coming
in i'm not sure that's quite
discuss discuss uh no i don't think
she's the new dominant companies i think
she's
just a you know just just an influential
player like a number of
influential players uh you know what
we're looking for
is uh you know going to be the new well
who's going to be a chief of staff i
mean one of the things that um
i think many thought was weird about um
johnson's
approach to government was he had a very
senior aide the most influential aid
dominic cummings
um uh who um
was very powerful when it came to ideas
uh refused
to be chief of staff but uh was sort of
a block on a proper chief of staff being
appointed because he didn't want
somebody
um on top of him it's slightly odd that
the prime minister thought that was a
a sort of sensible organizational
uh relationship he does need a chief of
staff but
you know like all success really
successful prime ministers particularly
in a time of crisis
he does need a person or people
with big ideas and with the ability to
grasp the magnitude of problems now
let's be clear uh minera mercer has been
um
in a slightly quieter way quite an
influential figure she will continue to
be an influential
uh figure it's not obvious
to me that she has that sort of
um a breadth of economic vision or
and and and sort of breadth of
geopolitical ideas
that cummings had um and
you know given that johnson himself is
enthused by
ideas but doesn't seem to come up with
um
you know he's not like thatcher uh you
know he doesn't have a
a sort of coherent vision of how to
remake
uh britain um and he's
he's probably not really like blair
either in the sense that blair
took uh the lessons of thatcher and
remade
labor for a generation uh as
as an electable part as an electable
party as you said
we just don't know um what um
boris johnson really stands for
um and i think at a time of such crisis
and we've talked about the big
challenges
uh he faces that is a problem i suppose
the one
and and i think he also has um
one uh sort of
in sort of personality trait that i'm
not sure is quite right for these times
um historically he's been very
successful because he's such an optimist
um but i fear that in the last few
months
he's he's rather let himself down and
possibly get the country down by
finding it impossible not to finish
whatever
statement he's making about these awful
times on a sort of well it's all going
to be all right because
testing is going to sort us out within a
matter of weeks or a vaccine is going to
sort us out within a matter of weeks
i mean picking up on what um you know
james has just said
there is absolutely no doubt that the
most you know important and positive
thing we've seen
uh in the last couple of weeks uh uh is
is a couple of vaccines that show
extraordinary efficacy i mean more than
90
efficacy is is is much better than
anybody thought as quickly as this and
that's that is tremendously
good news and there are lots of signs
coming out of the
um astrazeneca oxford trials that that's
going to be a good vaccine
but we should be under no illusion that
logistically
it will be impossible to vaccinate
enough people to give us
you know notorious phrase herd immunity
till
late spring early summer it's just going
to be impossible and that means we are
going to be living with some kind of
restrictions
and we're going to be living with at
best sluggish economic growth
for months and months and months and
i i'm not sure the prime minister has
quite done the right kind of job
uh which is what you it's a sort of
wartime spirit job of basically
conditioning the british people to
recognize
it ain't gonna get spectacularly better
for quite some time i'm afraid we've got
years of living with the legacy of all
of this
um you know i don't want to sound
pessimistic
or too pessimistic we will get through
it but we'll only get through it if we
are realistic
about the costs well robert since i've
got you here then let's pick up on that
and then i'll finish off with katie and
james up if you think growth next year
is going to be sluggish may well be and
it could be sluggish in 2023
i mean i wouldn't entirely discount that
very suddenly we'll be in the roaring
20s
uh this time the 2020s not the 1920s
because if we were
sitting here in 1920 none of us would
have predicted
the roaring twenties of that decade in
america so
but i take your point that you know
there could be sluggish growth for the
next year or two
if that's the case and given all these
huge
spending demands that now rain down on
the treasury from the green new deal
to defence spending to the northern uh
infrastructure investment what are the
constraints
what are the rules that now govern
how much the government can borrow
uh i mean this is um uh a bit of a
a nightmare question well in the sense
that in the sense that the
so we're getting you know we've got an
announcement
uh as we speak from the prime minister
saying that defense spending
uh will rise something like 10 a year
right um obviously armed forces
thrilled uh lots of tory mps in
particular
thrilled but the impression has been
created
that once you i mean we're probably
going to add
something like 400 billion pounds to the
national debt
400 billion pounds to the national debt
uh this fiscal year uh to the end of
march i mean these are
outside of a war these are unprecedented
increases
uh in the national debt and the
impression one has gone at the moment is
that the government has sort of decided
well you know in the context that debts
rising
um by that much anyway what's another 5
10 15 20 billion pounds on top of that
in other words
we seem to have entered a period where
the psychology of the government
is um everything is of
affordable because by the old rules
everything that's happening at the
moment is completely unaffordable and
since we're still alive we might as well
just borrow and borrow and borrow and do
all the things
that we haven't done over the last 10
years and
you know that's plainly not
sustainable for the long term
it's sustainable for a few months to
cheer people up
it's sustainable for a bit to get the
animal spirits going again so
maybe the private sector is a bit more
confident and we get a revival of the
economy
uh because you know there is a bit more
demand there and
you know a bit more spending there and
you know and and
and just to be clear i don't rule out
that towards the end of the year
um there's uh you know a significant
economic bounce if you know the vaccine
is a huge breakthrough
activity will return the issue is not
whether activity returns
it's um you know i mean if we are back
to the roaring twenties then heaven help
us
uh because we all know what uh
that kind of economic uh
uh bubble and it was a bubble led to it
led
to the great crash and the decade of the
depression
and you know one of the things i worry
about and you know is
that this this this recovery we're
getting into
is you know if if if if we get a roaring
20s scenario of of of of that kind of
asset price inflation
it will prick at some point and if we're
very unlucky it'll
burst in a way that then leaves us with
years and years of misery um
uh and what worries me and genuinely
worries me is there is no sign of any
you know leading western government
thinking
about what this level of indebtedness
you know rising actually means and you
know i i don't take comfort from the
rise in the stock market it looks like a
bubble to me
uh and it just shows again
how short-termist everybody is being um
i know i'm i'm slightly renowned for
being gloomy about these things what i
would say is we've just got to be
we've really got to have an honest
debate about all of this and and
um uh you know i applaud the prime
minister for
you know essentially encouraging us to
believe
that you know there is there will be
significant life after this that's true
but we we've got to have an honest
debate about the cost
james who now speaks for the
northern blue wall i i think that is a
very good question
andrew i think you know you saw the
boris johnson's article the northern
research group of tory mps
he said to them look you know you've got
to kind of keep me honest on the north
on this leveling up agenda
i i think you will see more of that i
think it's worth remembering that
the chancellor is a yorkshire mp and i
think this is the big question
they've got to if the tories have the
2019 election the queen of the tour is
an odd electoral coalition
but they won bolsover grimsby and red
car
but they also held cities of london and
westminster
cheltenham and winchester so what
they've got to do they've got to find a
way
to keep that coalition together for 2024
and i think that you know the the
prerequisite of holding those blue wall
seats is to deliver on leveling up and
what does that mean i mean that has to
mean
better broadband better transport and
better high streets i think those are
the kind of tangible things in people's
lives
but they are going to look to see and if
the tory government cannot deliver that
by the time of the next election voters
aren't going to thank them for getting
brexit done they will just simply
i mean revert back either not vote or
revert back to
their old traditional tribal allegiances
to labor i mean the tories have a
have a small window to deliver
improvements in these voices lives
before we all these voters can give up
on the experiment
but what evidence we have given the
government's record on covet
and the billions that have been spent on
test and trace and on ppe a lot of it
ending up in the pockets of their
cronies or
relatives or friends
what evidence do we have that the
johnson administration
has the ability to deliver when it talks
about
a massive increase in wind farms and
moving to electric cars by 2030
even now talking about getting rid of
every gas heater in every
home in the country what evidence is
that they're capable of doing
any of that correctly look
i think you are right that as robert
said you know in terms of handling this
crisis
the uh east asian democracies have done
a much better job
than the western ones and you've you've
seen how far the west has fallen behind
in terms of public administration
i think the big question really the big
political question is
what happens with this oxford vaccine
and
and
if it is if it works and how quickly can
it be rolled out
i think that you know i think it because
so so far as you say right
andrew you know the british state has
not distinguished itself in its handling
of this crisis and nor is the johnson
government but if you got to a stage
where
there was a british vaccine that the uk
had a large number of doses of
and it successfully managed to immunize
a large percentage of the population
rapidly and was able to move from that
uh to reopening the economy and getting
things going again
i i think that would make people think
that the government had more of a grip
and was
more competent i don't think this so i
think the importance of this vaccine
which is the thing that breaks this
cycle of lockdowns which was absolutely
killing the johnson government
that is i think the crucial political
questioning does this oxford vaccine
work when we get its results in the next
uh week or two
and how quickly can the government
manage to roll it out
casey final question to you in this
segment of the show um
whatever troubles mr johnson faces and
there are many
and uh he's still got a lot of big
decisions to
take a green new deal doesn't solve all
his problems
by any means but he does have an ally
doesn't he the labour party
seems to be doing his best to help the
tories
yes just as everyone wants to talk about
blue on blue
we had labour infighting resurfaced this
week regarding jeremy corbyn and his
suspension from the labour party
over the ehrc report into anti-semitism
in the party
now jeremy corbyn was suspended after he
uh
said in a statement a while ago that the
problem was overstated
um but then uh committee the nec
uh decided that he would be reinstated
to the party this quickly led to
a big round because people pointed out
that kirstama
had alleged he was going to take strong
actions only to let jeremy corvin back
in
and it seemed as though kirsten stammer
is going to succeed in annoying every
single group
um both the jewish community and
supporters of jeremy corbyn who are
annoyed he was suspended in the first
place
and after i think sleeping on it
overnight kirstalmer
chose to withdraw the whip from jeremy
corbyn so you now have a situation where
it i think one way to imagine it is
jeremy corbyn is a labour member and
could go to labour party conference but
he's not a labour mp
he's an independent mp um and i think it
has once again lifted the lid
on in fighting in the party and the fact
that there is
not uh you know a huge number but
definitely a significant
portion of current labor mps who are
loyal to jeremy corbyn over kierstarma
and is that going to be difficult for
the labour leader going forward
it definitely makes it harder for
kirstalma to say it's a completely new
party
if you have lots of members coming out
and mps saying that they
backed jeremy corbyn thank you robert
peston katie balls
thanks for joining us for our first
segment of spectator tv this week
let's move on to our next brexit
deadlines have come and gone an
agreement
has yet to be reached but they haven't
really got much time now it all has to
be done and
dusted one way or another by the end of
the year and that's
fast approaching we get smoke signals
coming out
almost every week sometimes it looks
like a deal is going to be done
then others look like maybe we're not so
sure so where are we now
i'm joined by james forsyth our
political editor and wolfgang muncher
editor of euro intelligence welcome to
you wolfgang to james first give us an
update where we are at the talks as you
see it
so today's news is that michelle barnier
was meant to brief
eu member states on what's been going on
he's decided not to do that
that is seen as a positive sign that
they want to keep a lid on what is being
discussed
in these negotiations because they think
they are making some progress and they
think that letting in
you know too much sunlight on it might
not work
i mean the negotiations are undoubtedly
more intensive this week
uh simon coveny uh the irish prominence
that described it as gonna move weak for
both sides and i think both sides are
moving but i think they are moving in a
crab-like fashion rather than like
gazelles
so i think it's too early to say that
you know oh it's all going to be done
but i think things are definitely
looking more positive than they were
a week or so ago and i think there's
also this which is
i think both sides as you get closer to
this deadline
are beginning to consider the enormity
of what
a no deal would mean and no deal
wouldn't just be an economic event
indeed
i actually think given that this deal is
going to be a relatively
thin deal i think i mean i think it's i
mean the consequence of no deal will be
far more geopolitical with economic
and i i struggle to see how it does not
poison
uk eu relations forward for a decade uh
and i think that that would obviously
bleed over into cooperation on you know
foreign policy challenges such as russia
uh uh or you know the western response
to china and the like
so i think i think that kind of the
geopolitical forces are pushing both
sides to do a deal
but you know uh on uh issues of
substance it is still hard and i think
the ultimate question comes down to it
is
you know is if you get more movement on
the level playing field
i i struggle to think that the whole
deal will fail over fish that there
won't be some
way found to kind of massage uh the
fishing question widget which is
obviously politically emotive on both
sides of a channel
but i think there is a kind of sense
that you know if fish is the last issue
the two sides really ought to be able to
fix that
wolfgang let me pick up another one
james just made there when the british
started
these uh negotiations in the latest
round there was all this talk of you
know we want
we are up for canada plus plus plus
you know we want everything in the
canadian free trio trade deal and a lot
more on services and all the rest of it
it doesn't look good to me wolfgang that
even if we get a deal we'll be anywhere
near that
this is much more likely to be canada
dry than canada plus plus plus
oh it's canada dry and very dry indeed
it's it's a very thin deal i think
people people we
we're talking about the deal versus node
and i agree with james failure to
to to do a deal is indeed um uh
uh a crisis uh in eu uk relations
especially if it was an acrimonious
failure
uh as opposed to the failure where both
sides say you know let's just
you know stop for now and try again next
year and try to do as little damage in
the meantime
there are some mitigating measures both
sides could take
but um you know the deal the deal will
be
thin and i think the big shock for many
people will be when brexit happens and
there is a deal
how how little how little this deal will
comprise now there won't be tariffs
there won't be quotas that is sure some
some achievement
but tariffs are you know three percent
on average
uh okay the average may not be
meaningful because the tariffs on fish
on certain
categories of fish are going to be very
high the terrorism cars are going to be
high
uh there will be very visible tariffs
but on average three percent that's
that's off that's less than a you know a
bad day's exchange rate movements
so this is not going to be the big the
big economic the big economic issue but
people will realize no there isn't a
deal for financial services there isn't
a deal for any other services there may
not be a deal for
even for university degrees and the
recognition of professional
qualifications we
haven't seen the text nobody has really
nobody really knows what is being agreed
nobody has
been able to study the text i know you
know
the people in the european parliament
get very nervous not because time is
running out but because they feel that
they have to
ratify a text that is possibly 1800
pages long
in a week and they may just see things
or discover things as you know
ratification is a meaningful procedure
it's not just a vote
to to they will vote in favor of it but
you know a long text will
have implications for companies nobody
knows what's in it
so even if this is agreed and uh
you know it could be a very very messy a
very messy procedure
why has it come to this you know there
was talk
you know this could be the greatest free
trade deal in history the uk economy the
eu
eu economy in regulatory terms at the
moment they're totally aligned
the the smoothest free trade between
them of any
uh parts of the world so therefore it
shouldn't be that difficult
even though we are leaving to move to a
very ambitious free trade deal
why has that not happened and
probably i know people don't like to ask
questions like this
these days days who's to blame
both sides are to blame the eu misjudged
the brexit process from the start of the
finish and they still
is still misjudging it uh there is
always
it has played too much um uh into
there was too much hope that the uk
would extend the deadline in july which
he could have done
they didn't believe johnson when he said
he would not extend
they did not expect to be in the
position that they are now that boris
johnson hasn't folded yet which this is
something they expected because the
assumption in brussels has been
the uk needs this deal more urgently
than the eu for that reason
the uk has an interest in concede in
conceding
some of the points the eu has done some
made some unreasonable demands in the
beginning
like asking or like demanding that the
ecjs continues to play a role
uh like asking the uk to align its
regulatory policies on labor markets
environmental standards
and on state a to the eu these
negotiations have brought a lot of
progress on these issues so the
differences that we have now in these
negotiations
there are still important differences
but they are not the differences between
good or bad so even if if if the
if one side were to give in more than
the other um
in in in the face that we have achieved
at this point
it wouldn't be a disaster it might just
be a you know bad pr for one side
uh but it it wouldn't be you know it is
a fairly balanced
deal that we have at the moment uh there
are reasonable tradeoffs to make like on
fish i mean the uk wants to sell fish on
the european markets the uk
sells a lot of fish to spain you know uk
is a country that eats court and
and exports mackerel and spain is a
country that eats mackerel and exports
costs so so
one would assume that the two come to
some kind of sensible agreement given
the given the situation
and on competition policy i have
sympathies with the use point that that
if there is a if you have a large trade
agreement or
a trade agreement with a large trading
partner next door that you want to have
a broad
a broad consensus about state aid and in
fact the uk is not the problem here
germany is far more it gives far more
trade
state a to companies so this is a bit of
a of a straw man debate i mean the
eu has a massive trade surplus with the
eu and we're talking about a level
playing field
issue in the other direction it doesn't
really make sense you
in the uk should be raising level
playing field issues given that it has a
deficit
so so um so in the end we're dealing
with straw man issues that that could in
that should
rationally be resolved the danger now is
not the trait the trade negotiators are
doing a good job they
will identify a landing zone i'm pretty
sure
at some point next week the difficulty
they have
is to ensure that when they come up with
this tradings or this this
landing zone um that the two principals
you know boris johnson in the uk
and you know for all you know probably
emmanuel macron on the eu side
will both in the end do the right thing
and not start
to you know extend this and find another
way of
of um or making another unreasonable
demand that the other side would then
expect so an accident that's possible
will it require that if there is to be a
deal at the the 11th hour and it's quite
often the 11th hour these things
happen but will it require
a political intervention at a
nation-state level
and by that i mean will it require
angela merkel
to have to have a quiet word with
emmanuel macron
uh chancellor merkel perhaps with the
backing of the swedes and the dutch and
maybe even the spanish and the italians
as well
and just try and find a way to help him
down from the fish issue
perhaps find ways even of compensating
him in other ways
in other words it will take the the top
nation state leaders in the end
to make some kind of political
intervention if there is a
if this thing is not wrapped up by say
early next week then that will
undoubtedly happen
uh uh mackerel will talk mackel never
put the interests of the german never
entered use the german car industry in
these negotiations she never
she was she really stayed out of she
prioritized the unity of the eu
which was an intelligent negotiating
position but macro hasn't done the same
macro
has actually invoked the interest of the
french fishing industry
now the german car industry is a
multitude bigger than the french fishing
industry
so you know mackel would have a point to
say to micron i didn't do this but you
are doing this so let's basically be
reasonable and cut a deal here
uh i don't think that germany can
compensate france for the loss of
fishing so that would have to be
negotiated with the uk
and there are ways to negotiate in in
terms of
transitional periods in terms of quarter
arrangements i
you know the uk has enough water there
is no shortage of
there's no shortage of water there's no
four shortage of fish this is a
very strange dispute to have this is not
like we're not really dealing with
serious economic issues here but um but
it's it's mostly perceptional issues
so there should be a deal but i
completely agree this will not be
decided by the negotiators the
negotiators are preparing the ground
what they're calling landing zones
that's all they can do
and neither lord frost nor mashimi
shelbani are in a position to force the
hand of macron they do however obviously
talk to both sides
and if macron is not at this point not
briefing his people then that's probably
to do with the fact that
he hasn't yet got the clearance for for
compromise
they they need to talk they need to they
need to get some more details
uh he he will he you know the french are
recognizing that they need to compromise
on fish in principle they do
but the question is to which extent they
do and whether that is still compatible
with the with the uk position
um so the fish is a serious issue
um that that will that could still
jeopardize the thing it's not a
substantive issue in the sense that you
know we're talking about one
two one one billion or two billion
pounds of of of of trade which is minute
compared to the other stuff
you know the fact that we haven't got
anything on financial services is much
much more serious
uh let me go back to james wolfgang for
a minute and then i'll finish up with
you
uh james putting the bravado or the
public face aside
is there not some real concern in
westminster or in whitehall
that there isn't a deal not because the
deal is going to be that great or
actually even if the deal has a
deleterious effect on the economy
it will probably in the short term all
be hidden by the fallout from covent
we're not really going to be able to
measure now all the economic models we
were preparing to measure what was going
to happen
have really been shot to hell because of
covert now we won't really know
what was covered what was no deal brexit
but there's a kind of symbolic
reputational issue for the government
is there not which along the lines of
you've been uselessly handling covered
and you can't even get a deal on leaving
the eu
yeah i mean there are three big dangers
the first is the geopolitical one
the second thing is not getting a deal
would make the northern ireland
situation much
more difficult and if the uk government
pressed ahead with the clauses in the
internal market bill
that would strain relations with the
incoming biden administration
but i mean the biggest issue is is is
your last point on competence andrew
because
i think in the event of a deal you would
see both sides
move to keep trade flowing uh i think
you would see the eu
take a relatively light touch approach
to checks you know
let's keep things moving i think in the
event of no deal because i think
i think no deal would inevitably be to
wolfgang's point but inevitably
acrimonious i can't imagine the two
negotiators shaking hands and saying
well i'm not shaking hands whatever
you're meant to do in this in this in
this day and age
um and saying well let's sit back down
around the table in six months i think
it would be a
political row and a blame game i i think
in that situation
the eu would take a much more uh
fingernail checking approach
to uh border checks uh it's well known
that there are people around emmanuel
macron who take the view that you know
six months of that and the brits will be
back at the table and much more inclined
to compromise on fish
and i think the danger for the
government is people will say
well we voted to leave in 2016 why
wasn't the country
ready for this uh and the other danger
is
you know we voted for you to get brexit
done and now brexit's all over the news
every night again
what's going on wolfgang let me finish
with you and then we're going to move
across the atlantic
uh maybe i suggested my previous
question that maybe angela merkel would
have to intervene at a political level
with the support
of others maybe what would break the log
drama get us through this
given the geopolitical consequences that
james is talking
about would be an angler frank summit of
mr johnson and
president macron mr johnson speaks
fluent french
they both like to drink wine together
the french like a british politician
that can speak another language
partly because it doesn't happen very
often and
there are huge anglo-french
relationships at stake here
our intelligence cooperation has never
been greater and france is in the middle
of a huge fight against islamism
a fact that mr macron is taking the lead
the only two militaries that really
matter in europe
are france and britain and britain's
just announced a massive extension of
the money we spend
we have two world-class aircraft
carriers one of which is already being
deployed the other
shortly they could work with france too
there are so
many issues the deployment of force
britain's already helping
uh the french out in mali with heavy
lift capabilities
if there has to be a european
intervention somewhere or another
it'll only be the british and the french
that can really do it
couldn't all these issues if they were
out in the open in the future
you know i know now mi6 is now embedded
with dgse in paris
dgse is now regularly with mi6 in london
shouldn't that matter a lot more than
fish
it would be funny if that all that were
sacrificed at the
uh over a dispute of fish it's it's um
it's one of the strangest debates i
think i've
i have followed but i completely agree
these strategic impacts that you have
all these strategic
relationships that you've mentioned the
you know uk is a member of the u.n
security council is another another
another important
issue to to to to consider from a
european perspective
um these are uh points that have
unfortunately not played a role in the
european debate
i would however think that macro
understands this uh this is probably one
thing that um mccor understands better
than the other
other european leaders who are more
focused on the internal market
and domestic policy issues macaron too
is focused on domestic policy issues
my reading of his position on fish is
that he is merely
putting up a fight which he needs to do
in france it's important that the
president stands up for the small guy
and he needs to do that if he didn't do
that
others would do this and he has an
election campaign coming up
in 22. so my reading of the situation is
that he will
put up a fight but in the end agree
uh it would indeed be a failure of
french policy
if he didn't and indeed it would be a
disaster for a french fisherman if there
wasn't a deal either
so this is because then i get no access
it wouldn't make sense
the position so so there is a
possibility as you say
a franco uk summit is a possibility
i think they might just settle this on
the phone frankly uh the issues are very
clear
uh that in the end they have to both be
seen to be fighting and
and settle this there is an accident
possibility as they always are in these
negotiations especially since the eu
has other crises at the moment about the
year budget
of hungary these are issues that are
kind of distracting them at the moment
it could be that they
are you know taking the eye of the ball
that is quite possible
but uh the under under any normal
circumstances there should be a deal
happening before the end of the year the
you know it might not even happen next
week the eu has several
mechanisms or it's at least considering
mechanisms
to delay the whole ratification process
for example this thing could go until
christmas
and then they're ratified later that is
a possibility it's not yet fully
explored legally
you know it's is uncharted territory but
it's not clear that it's
impossible so and they will do anything
to get it to
to they will not let this fail over you
know time is running out that's not
going to be
the issue right we'll come back and uh
mark our card as we reach the end game
of this process it's been a joy to have
you on
spectator tv today wolfgang muncher
there
let's turn to the continued fallout for
our final segment uh
from the u.s election mr trump still
refusing to concede
filed lawsuits in a number of
battleground states not clear they're
getting anywhere
joe biden's announced some of his white
house team he's attacked the president
for refusing him access to the
classified briefings that are
normally afforded a president-elect
during the 11-week interregnum
between election and inauguration let's
go first to freddie gray our usa doesn't
just get an update from him
pretty where where are we on the basis
various
challenges to the results and some of
the battleground
states well uh i mean team trump
keeps promising uh a big reveal uh one
of his lawyers sydney powell said they
were about to unleash
the kraken um but so far we haven't seen
the kraken yet
we've just seen rudy giuliani give this
very strange appearance in court
um and i'm actually i think rudy
giuliana is a lot brighter than a lot of
people give him credit for and i think
he's been a very effective operator
throughout his career
but they are they're setting themselves
up
for mockery at the moment because they
keep making a lot of
uh claims that that this great reveal is
going to come we're going to see how
it's either dominion the computer
software uh
rigged the election for biden or that
there are masses of dead people voting
or that the mail-in balloting system was
massively fraudulent on an epic scale
but they just don't seem to be producing
clear enough evidence to convince people
and the problem for them is not
necessarily that they're wrong it's that
the large majority of americans just
want this election to be done and they
want to move on
i don't think at the moment i haven't
seen
any sufficient evidence to suggest
they're going to be able to prove
that the election was fraudulent i do
think there almost certainly was for
audience because
mail-in balloting is a terrible business
and
and particularly in this recent american
election we've seen it's a mess because
you have different states
having different systems and nobody has
been quite sure what's going on for the
last two weeks
so i think you have an urgent case for
electoral reform
but i don't see how the republicans can
prove that they've been robbed
well stick with us freddie let me bring
in now candace zone so we welcome to
spectator
tv she's a conservative commentator
author of blackout founder of blexit
it's an organization urging black
americans to stop voting democrat
which they do in huge numbers uh you
might know from her days as the
communications director of turning point
candace owns welcome to spectator tv
um is it not time now
for mr trump to concede and move on
no uh and i i strongly disagree uh with
freddie's assessment that the american
people want this election to be over
with it's quite the opposite you had 73
million people
uh voting for donald j trump and all of
these people right now are being gaslit
by the media
there was once upon a time where the
media would tell the people story
right so right now we've just had the
media uh telling their own version of
events not speaking to any americans who
are
presenting tons of evidence they send it
to me of their own their own ballots uh
not being cast not being counted
uh people showing you that their dead
relatives um have voted in this election
this was one of the most insane
elections that we've ever had mind you
the media the same very same media
who prepped us all year saying that this
election we're not going to figure out
the result it's going to be unlike any
election we've ever had
because of cobit 19 and male invalids
it's going to take weeks and weeks and
weeks
for us to be able to count now that same
exact media is saying
well never mind trump just needs to
concede and we had an election where we
all went to bed at 2am trump was winning
by a lot
and then suddenly we woke up and we were
told that the exact opposite happened
they stopped counting
and suddenly there was a massive dump of
ballots and joe biden was in the lead
um everything about this feels
fraudulent and to say
you should just certify the election
because the media is ready to move on
which is what we're really getting at
the media
is ready to move on the media has been
ready to move on from trump honestly
since he won
in 2016. right wrong but you called the
election
fraudulent and talk about the media but
even donald trump's
own lawyers in key states
are not alleging fraud in arizona
and pennsylvania his own lawyers have
said we're not alleging fraud
so it's not just the media the fact is
you haven't got the evidence to show
fraud in any kind of great scale
which of trump's lawyers because you're
you're making that i'll give you two his
lawyer in arizona when asked by the
judge said
we are not alleging fraud or the
stealing of the election we're talking
about quote good
faith or errors that's donald trump's
lawyer
or in the case in montgomery county
pennsylvania
the judge asked the lawyer are you
alleging fraud here
no we are not alleging fraud okay so the
error
okay if the if we're talking about the
word fraud and you're and you're
reducing it down to the word fraud
what we have realized that is that these
errors that seem to be happening these
accidental errors where they transfer
votes
from trump to joe biden only seem to be
happening one way so whether you want to
say
it was human error which is what the
dominion voting systems is arguing at
this point in america
that it was all human error and
something happened and someone pressed
the wrong button
fine but the results are fraudulent to
the american people you cannot just move
on
when 73 million people do not trust the
election
process and do not trust the votes and
it was done in a year where you
transformed
the election process you guys would
don't do this in the uk you guys don't
calculate
and do an electronic system they don't
do this in canada they force this
they they force this in america because
of cobit 19.
and if you go back and look at my
rhetoric you're the one one that used
the word fraudulent
yes fraudulent and fraud mean the same
thing
i give you two examples of his own
lawyers not
alleging fraud in two key states where
did the divine
dominion voting machine where what
evidence is
presented that that's made a difference
well i i'm not sydney powell so you're
you're speaking to me as if i'm
you know i'm not the person who
presented dominion voting systems as an
issue or an error
that candice you're not in michigan in
michigan i'm saying that
the votes were changed 6 000 people were
voted who voted for donald j trump got
changed to joe biden
um so that happened in america and
they've come out and they said that was
a human who pressed the wrong button
you know but are you talking about
antrim county in michigan
i'm not sure uh it could be antrim
county guess correct but what happened
was
the original report in antrim county was
wrong these votes hadn't been moved
it was the report of the voting that was
wrong not the voting machine that was
right and it was right
no that was dominion voting systems that
was their argument but the other people
are saying that it was a huge
dominion voting system is saying it was
a human error and sidney powell and
trump's campaign is saying it was not a
human error that the system was designed
to be able to do this
and this is what he's talking about when
sydney powell is saying that they have
more evidence
that they're willing to present and
rather than allow them and afford them
the right to do this the entire
mainstream media is saying just move on
it's not here why not just allow them
this is what our system allows for
allow the due process to go through why
are we trying to sweep this under the
rug and move on and say
well we don't have any evidence yet so
it needs to be closed again this is the
same media that told us this election
was going to take months and months and
months to count including joe biden
himself
joe biden hillary clinton hillary
clinton boldly said that joe biden if he
lost should not concede
so i don't understand how the media can
then just flip and say you know what the
exact opposite and gaslight all the
american people who they've been
conditioning to believe
that this election was going to take
months to transform i mean to call
okay i want i want to move on but i
don't it's not a question i would just
say
before we do of sweeping things under
the carpet it's it's a question
of looking very carefully at all the
evidence people who take your side
present and then discovering that in
most cases it doesn't stand
up to scrutiny that doesn't mean
sweeping it under
the carpet but indulge me
let's assume that i'm right that at some
stage mr trump does have to concede
joe biden is the next president the 46th
president of the united states
will donald trump run again do you think
i don't know that's a good question um i
i would i would hope you would run again
i mean i i don't think that any person
this is going to be
a bad election result no matter what
because as you're seeing in recent
polling there are 73 million people who
do not believe that this
election was executed in good faith and
we have been saying this since long
before the election i've been saying
this since march
the idea of transforming the entire
election system
in one year and expecting states to be
able to do with this um and
having so many people's voices censored
right people that are speaking out about
their own election fraud stories are
right now being censored
uh by the big tech i just don't think
it's going to
it's going to be a very testy time in
america and it already has been for the
last four years
um so perhaps he will run if he did
obviously i would support him i think he
should
um but it's wrong and i'll tell you what
is fraudulent is all of the mainstream
media and the tech people
calling president biden i'm calling
former vice president biden the
president-elect
that is incorrect it is wrong language
he should be called a presidential
candidate this election has not been
called by the states okay i don't like
let's try and keep we keep on track here
because we haven't got too much
much time mark our card and
on this now the of let's again assume mr
trump doesn't run
i mean i perfectly understand he may
well but let's assume he doesn't
tell us what will the battle for the
soul of the gop
be like it's going to have to stick with
what's been dubbed as trumpism
uh the gop has completely changed it's
not it's no longer the establishment
republican party
and when i say that i'm talking about
the john mccain republican party it's
completely transformed
over the last four years for the better
it's become more inclusive
what you can see by looking at uh the
early exit polling numbers
you know hispanics largely i think 36
percent voted for donald j trump this
election
uh black uh women and doubled their
support for donald trump black men voted
18
for trump so despite all of the rhetoric
of trying to smear and libel him as a
racist the party has actually become
incredibly more inclusive
um and that's in large part uh because
donald j trump was a
a more cultural figure and what i mean
by that um
is that he was able to communicate his
message in a more effective way
and he felt more attainable to the
american people
and i get that he's a you know he's a
boisterous busty billionaire from new
york
uh but he does when he speaks to people
he's very much a blue collar and able to
relate to them in a different way
and i think that's good let's be clear
what is you think because
it's interesting what you said you're
saying that even without mr trump and
maybe actually be with mr trump we don't
know
but even without mr trump the republican
party will still
to at least a substantial degree room
become and remain a trumpian party
absolutely without without question and
if that's the case candace
who in the absence of mr trump perhaps
he's going off to start his own
new tv station or whatever it is he
wants to do
um in the absence of mr trump what kind
of republicans today
do you think best embody these trumpian
values um there are a lot of different
elements of trump so if you're talking
about just being a person
who you know doesn't bulk when the
mainstream media is on their backs
somebody like ron desantis
right i mean he has he has stood firm in
the kobit 19 christie gnome
um in south dakota uh has been has stood
firm on her policies despite the media
creating a pressure campaign against her
on covet 19.
um so what we're really talking about is
someone who does not bend to the will of
the mainstream media because the
mainstream media does not represent
americans at this moment
and i would and i would i would even go
so far to say the mainstream media
doesn't represent
uh people in the uk as well right they
get completely misled that may be the
case but although i i usually you manage
to work the mainstream media into
every answer i and i i get that you're a
part of the mainstream media and it can
be offensive but you have to
you have to call it accurately you know
you you understand
they just keep misdiagnosing the people
that they are supposed to be
representing and rather than
get an answer without the mainstream
media being involved uh
it seems to me i i mean i know what you
you are it's clear what you want
uh and you're certainly not alone in
that that even without mr trump
you think that mr trump has transformed
the republican party it's a very
different party
not just from the old east coast country
club republican party
but also even from the the goldwater
reagan west coast
republican party as well and you think
he's made a big change there
i understand that but you will know
there are still plenty of people in the
republican party
that see this as their chance if mr
trump departs
to go back to not a country club
republican party
but maybe a more reaganized kind of a
republican party
so there is going to be a battle for the
soul of the republican party is that not
i don't believe so i think the
republican party has actually never been
more united
um and there was definitely a fracturing
when he first hit the stage in 2015
um and there were many people that never
you know the never trump parade and
republicans did not stand behind them
but all of those republicans stood
behind him this election cycle
um so you know despite i won't i won't
say mainstream media but despite
depictions depictions the republican
party
uh is is actually very much together in
this moment and i don't think anybody
wants to go backwards
let me bring freddie in then i'll come
back and finish with you candace
uh uh freddie what do you make of what
you've heard
well i i mean i hate to be accused of
siding with the mainstream media i've
always tried
uh not to god you're out of this well
now
it is it's just i hate i've been busted
and my closet never trumpism has been
exposed
uh but i do i i do think it's very
interesting about what happens to the
republican party after trump and i do
think we have to have this conversation
despite
the ongoing contestation i mean i'm
just interested in how much you can
withdraw trump from the scene
and still have the movement he created
and i think one of his failings as a
leader and i hope candace doesn't object
too much to this
is that he hasn't established a movement
that can work politically he hasn't
taken over washington in the way that he
could have done he hasn't even taken
over the republican party in the way
that he could have done and so when he
goes if he goes
you will see this revert to the mean and
i think it will fail
i think the bush-era republican party is
destined to fail
but trump hasn't established a party
that can go forward without him and i
wonder whether it can because
one of the reasons trump is loved and i
agree with candice he is really loved
um it's because of his flaws it's
because of his failings so a lot of
people when they talk about trumpism
without trump
they say they imagine a sort of a
trump-like person a national populist
who sort of doesn't have his flaws
doesn't send out nasty tweets
but but the tweets and and the trump the
element of the donald
is crucial to trumpism i wonder how it
can survive and i would like to put it
to candice that
i think the likely way in which it
survives is with donald trump jr running
in 2024 perhaps with candace owens
as his veep and is
i would i actually i agree very much
with your assessment and
i would all only say that if you look at
america
just through the lens of the past people
usually need a break from the from the
family
um so i don't know that donald trump jr
following donald j
trump works um but then again if people
feel like
uh they were not vindicated in the 2020
election cycle maybe it does but you are
correct but it's going to have to be
somebody
um who is a fighter and at the end of
the day that is that there are those are
the characteristics of donald j
trump like he's a fighter excuse my cat
has apparently jumped into this
um but uh it is yeah i i would
totally people have always asked me you
know am i going to run am i going to
jump in and throw my hat in the ring and
i always say the same thing trump said
20 years ago if i felt that my country
needed me
um and that i had to do what i would
i have no desires to do it i don't think
it's a fun job i think it's a sacrifice
and that too many people want to go in
for vain reasons
uh when in fact it's an incredibly
difficult job to lead a country
that's a brilliantly political answer
yeah
yeah thanks to me you're definitely
running candace that's uh you got that
answer down to a pat
listen we watched this election the
so-called young country
it seemed to be you had to be 75 plus
before you were allowed to be a
candidate
or a candidate succeeded donald trump uh
joe biden indeed who were the likely
alternatives
elizabeth warren bernie sanders i mean
all these people that combined ages come
to about 2.5 million years
uh isn't it time for a break and your
party your republican party and i
appreciate you're an insurgent in the
republican party
but it's too male pale and stale as well
you need to reach out and get a lot more
voters you
you did badly among a lot of the women's
vote you
need more ethnic votes you need to be
younger
i mean i'm i think of all that and i do
who am i
and you need a true believer if you take
the view the
the trumpian way is still the future you
need a true believer
so i think of all that and i look at you
on my zoom screen here
and i think who takes every box candice
own
just announce you're running today on
spectator tv
i love that i i love the encouragement
um you know i'm
i'm a different kind of person i've
never been one of those people that has
a plan everyone says to me what are you
gonna do in five years ten years
i'm a big believer that you you have
plans and god laughs
um and in four years
well played um you know obviously
there's there's a big energy for that
and and people really want to see that
but i'm being honest when i say that
every time i sit down with my husband
uh and talk about that i just say you
know if if it comes to that and i
thought that my country needed me i
would do it but i i
genuinely do believe that as a sacrifice
i love my life as it is
i get to say what i believe
unapologetically um and and i and i live
a great life i'm happily married and
with a kid on the way
so um the idea of sitting down and
plotting and planning to become the
president united states to me
there's just something about that that's
incredibly narcissistic and i just
i don't have that character tree but
when i if i do announce
i will definitively do it on spectator
tv we're going to hold you uh
to that i mean everything you say the
more i'm convinced i mean even the baby
is going to arrive in plenty of time
perfect little half black half white
baby half english half american it's
gonna be great
long before you need to start the
primary campaign trail
that'll be perfect and you're married to
a brit and it's about time there was a
brit
back in the white house as well that can
only make for an improvement
if you don't do that we might burn it
down again as we did in 1812
so it's all going well listen whether
you run or not
i hope you really come back and see us
on spectator tv
uh we wish you all the best for the
coming christmas season
uh and good luck with the baby thank you
so much
candace own thank you for joining us
indeed thanks all of our guests for
joining us on this
edition of spectator tv a very special
thanks
to our sponsor charles stanley charles
stanley is one of the uk's leading
wealth management firms one of the
oldest firms
on the london stock exchange now youtube
viewers
you can subscribe to our channel
whatever device you're on
just tap the red subscribe button below
the video
and then the bell icon that appears
afterwards this way you'll be notified
whenever we post a new video you'll
never
miss an episode of spectator tv as
always please
send us your thoughts we know there's
room for improvement to spectator tv at
spectator dot co dot uk
that's spectator tv at spectator dot co
dot uk we hope you join us again
next thursday for another the week in 60
minutes
bye bye
you